هذا وتظاهر عند مدخل مقر وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه في تلابيب عشرات من عائلات
الاسرى الاسرائيليين في غزه
ودعموني حكومه نتنياهو بالعمل للافراج عن
الاسرى بشكل فوري ورفعوا لافتات تدعو
للتوصل الى صفقه تبادل قبل فوات الاوان
وتزامنت هذه المظاهره مع اجتماع للمجلس
الوزري المصغر مساء الثلاثاء في وزاره
الدفاع لبحث جمله من القضايا المتعلقه
بسير الحرب على غزه من
قضيه الاسرى
المحتجزين معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام تصريحات كثيره هرتس هاليفي يف
جالنت وبنيامين نتنياهو مجمل ما جاء في
هذه التصريحات وان كان فيها اي شيء مختلف
عن السياق العام للتصريحات للمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في الايام
الماضيه هو فيها قاسم مشترك زين لا شك وهو
هو ان الجميع يتحدث ان عن ان هذه الحرب
سوف تطول وسوف تطول لاشهر كثيره هذه هي
ربما القاعده المشتركه او القاسم المشترك
بين كل هذه التصريحات وتاكيد على ان هذه
الحرب لن تنتهي سريعا كما يتوقع او كما
يمني الكثيرون ربما النفس حول العالم
وربما ايضا في اجزاء من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وتحديدا عائلات الاسرء
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين داخل قطاع غزه
الذين يردون انهاء هذه الحرب على الفور
والجنوح مباشره الى
مفاوضات تنتهي بوقف لاطلاق النار وتنتهي
بصفقه للتبادل ونحن نرى بان هذا الحراك
الشعبي زين يزداد يوما بعد يوم على اعتبار
ان عائلات الاسرى المحتجزين داخل قطاع غزه
يرون بان مواقف الحكومه الاسرائيليه وموقف
المجلس الحربي تقود باتجاه استمرار هذه
الحرب لاشهر كثيره دون احراز تقدم على
صعيد ملف الاسرى وهم يخشون من ان هذا
الامر من شانه ان يؤدي الى المساس بحياه
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل
قطاع غزه وربما ضياع امكانيه الافراج عنهم
او الفرصه للافراج عنهم من ناحيه اخرى
بنيمين نتنياهو يحاول في مقابل ذلك ان
يقيم ربما اي مجموعه مواجهه لهذه العائلات
وهي تتمثل بعائلات الجنود الذين قتلوا في
معارك قطاع غزه الذي يقول بنيامين نتنياهو
بانه يلتقيهم وهم يقولون له بان عليه ان
يواصل هذه العمليه ال البريه حتى تحقيق
اهدافها كي لا يذهب تذهب دماء القتلى
الجنود سدن وكان بنيامين نتنياهو يريد ان
يضع عائلات الجنود القتلى في مواجهه
عائلات الاسرى المعتقلين في داخل قطاع غزه
ويبرر عمليا اطاله عمر الحرب وما من شك في
ان اطاله عمر الحرب هو امر يخدم بنيامين
نتنياهو وحده على اعتبار انه كلما طالت
الحرب كلما بقي هو على كرسي رئاسه الوزراء
في اسرائيل وبالتالي هو يتشدد في مواقفه
في هذه الناحيه حتى ان بنيامين نتنياهو
ووزير الدفاع يتشدد في مساله الاستمرار في
العمليات العسكريه الكبرى التي نشاهدها
يوميا فيما يجنح الوزير بيني جانس والوزير
جادي ايزنكوت اعضاء مجلس الحرب الى
الانتقال الى مراحل اخرى في العمليه
البريه وربما تقليل كثافه النيران في داخل
قطاع غزه ولعل هذا ما يوضح ما قاله هير
سليفي من حرب باسلوب مختلف شكرا جزيلا لك
الياس كرام من تلابي باساليب مختلفه صحيح